[Music]
going to school in new orleans in the
early 2000s was dismal
with only one in four children scoring
at their standard grade level
the city school board was so corrupt
that the fbi started an investigation
and eventually put its president and 30
others into jail
on top of this almost all of the
teachers were organized in unions
this ensured that even the worst
teachers kept their job for life
idealistic educators and politicians
tried to change the system
but their efforts were blocked by those
in charge who did everything possible to
keep things as they were
then things got worse
in 2005 katrina a massive hurricane
struck the city and destroyed virtually
everything including
all schools as a result everyone left
the city
kids stopped going to school the school
board lost all of its funding
and the teachers lost their jobs leading
to unions losing all of their members
it was a true disaster for everyone
in the aftermath of katrina politicians
bureaucrats and educators
saw an opportunity to finally bring
change upon a system that had previously
failed so many kids in such a miserable
way
under the leadership of governor
kathleen blanco it was concluded that
while they didn't know the best solution
they did know that the system had to be
created using trial and error and
experimentation
they had an idea
instead of running a top-down system of
state schools their idea was to allow
independent charter schools to take over
charters are schools that are fully
state-funded free of charge and run by
independent entrepreneurs who follow
their mission
charter schools hire their own teachers
and set up their own curriculums
they often even build their own
facilities and then compete with one
another to attract new students
as a result of this bold effort to
reform a lot of philanthropists and
non-profit organizations
invested into new orleans education and
hundreds of charter schools opened up
parents and their children suddenly had
a lot of choices in picking schools
aligned with their ideas
regarding quality education the schools
that didn't attract enough children
closed down again
[Music]
in 2019 15 years later almost half of
all students performed at grade level
high school graduation rates increased
and college outcomes became
significantly better
new orleans had become the first large
american city that does not operate
a single traditional public school
the story of new orleans schools shows
what is possible when old structures
break down
and people have no choice but to leave a
damaged system
good people who are stuck in a bad
system then get an opportunity to start
fresh
parents and children have the
opportunity to choose for themselves the
type of schools that they believe in
how are the schools organized in your
country do you think that a reform of
that system would benefit the students
if so what change would you propose
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel
we try to explain complex subjects in
simple language and cartoons
to support students all around the world
in their learning
if you want to support us you can go to
www.patreon.com
sprouts and donate just one dollar from
many fans makes a big difference